that might help if certain reporters
actually knew anything about the
impeachment process anyway here with
more house Speaker Kevin McCarthy is
with us Mr Speaker great to have you why
isn't it maybe you should explain for
the rest of the media what the
difference is between an inquiry and an
actual impeachment and what you mean by
the Apex of power
well thank you for having me on Sean and
just so everybody understands when
Congress it's our role and
constitutional responsibility for
oversight to be have to have
investigations we just don't go out and
think of these investigations we have
people from the IRS came forth with
information we have President Joe Biden
who told us when he's running that they
received no money from China and he had
nothing to do with his business we've
now found that no we've had informants
that the FBI pays who came and said that
they think it's pay to play with the
bidens we've now found that the Biden
family created 20 shell companies while
he was vice president that he received
16 of 17 payments from Romania why he
was vice president of the family paid
all the way down well if you have all
these questions and you have an attorney
general who says one thing and IRS
whistleblower is coming forth saying
something else you want to know who's
lying and what's the information I would
think the Biden family would want to
know that when you move to an
impeachment inquiry it empowers Congress
Republicans and Democrats within their
subpoena to be able to get the answers
they need because we have found time and
again we haven't seen anything like this
since the Nixon Administration using
their government to shut down any time
we had a question I would think the
Biden family would want to clear their
name I mean if President Biden holds
ahead of time they've never got any
money and that Hunter Biden was the
smartest person he knew but now we found
out that he attended dinners and after a
dinner one dinner at Cafe Milano they
got 3.5 million from a Russian oligarch
who didn't get sanctioned after they
entered Ukraine and then we found that
Hunter got a Porsche these are questions
you have to understand why and why did
the government allow the statue of
limitations to run out on Hunter Biden
when they don't do that to the American
public the IRS makes you sign a waiver
to extend the statue of limitations so
it will not run out but why is why are
they being being treated differently and
we should know the answers to these
questions that empowers Congress
republics and Democrats of their
committee to be able to get the
information if somebody fights from
providing it to them well we even learn
more because the Russian oligarch former
first lady of Moscow at the Cafe Milano
where Joe dined with one of Hunter's
Farm business partners also that
included 120 million dollar real estate
investment on on top of the 3.5 million
the oligarch and Kazakhstan you know
wired the money so Hunter can get
himself a brand new Porsche how great is
that I wonder what he did for all that
uh to deserve that brand new car here's
where I want to go with this though
because to me I don't care how much the
media ignores it or the Democratic party
ignores it this is a real Joe Biden not
Hunter Biden bribery Scandal allegation
here we know now the following let's go
through the facts we know that Joe lied
both as a president and as a candidate
when he repeatedly denied ever speaking
to Hunter his brother or his words
anybody for that matter about their
foreign business dealings we know that
was a lie we know that Joe Biden
leveraged one billion taxpayer dollars
in loan guarantees for Ukraine and
insisted that a prosecutor be fired in
six hours as a result of that his son
Hunter who was sitting on a board that
he admitted on Good Morning America that
he had no experience to be on continued
to get paid ultimately it was millions
of dollars in the end and and my
question is tell me how that's not
influence peddling you know the bribery
statute Mr Speaker does not demand that
somebody benefit themselves financially
in this case the vice president has the
1023 form pointed out took a specific
action and his family you know was
involved in personal enrichment that
being Hunter based on his actions is
that bribery to you
well Sean everything that you just
talked about nobody in America knew
until you had a change in Congress the
FBI didn't act on their information from
their informant no one came forth they
took the words of this President and you
were right this isn't about Hunter Biden
this is about paying to play for the
Biden family because the money goes to
nine different members through shell
companies much like the informant set so
we will continue to follow the
information wherever it takes us and
provide it to the American public the
difference here is we don't do it for
political purposes we follow the
Constitution that's exactly what was
played out during the Nixon
Administration in Congress they voted to
have an impeachment inquiry and I I
raised it on this show not long ago that
because the actions of the Biden
Administration withholding information
that that would rise to the level where
we would need impeachment inquiry to
give the strength of the Congress to get
the information that we need need to
give to the American public and follow
through on our constitutional Authority
that is exactly what we're doing and
that's exactly what we'll continue to do
but Devon Archer's quoted as saying that
hiring Hunter was uh for them an
influence play he's those are his words
not my words we know Joe lied we know
the family benefited we know he took
actions why would a vice president ever
go to Ukraine and demand a prosecutor
get fired why would they leverage a
billion dollars in the relationship for
you know if it didn't benefit the Biden
family and just like the WhatsApp
message interesting is I'm sitting here
with my father a week later five million
dollars ends up in their coffers
now remember Sean you're not putting a
timeline to this we knew about Biden
going after the Attorney General because
he did that in his own words we never
knew because we just now got this what
just a week ago from Devon saying that
they were being pushed from Verismo
saying we need to do something about
this what was that in Dubai we need help
from DC five days later action or taken
yes when what you're finding is all this
information is being gathered is coming
through the investigations of the
Republican Congress that we will
continue to follow through and we will
continue to bring more and we will take
it wherever it takes and if it rises to
the level we will do our constitutional
duties and this is the part I want
America to know America has a right to
know if there was pay to play America
has a right to know if Garland is lying
to him America has a right to know in
this FBI whether they investigated and
are there pay to play when it comes to
this President I would think this
President would want to clear that name
rather rapidly give us his bank
statements
need information do you believe we are
looking at a bribery scandal with Joe
Biden who's now president actions he
took as vice president in exchange for
Family Enrichment
well I don't know of any other family
that puts together in government 20
shell companies why you're the Vice
President of America my family has no
shell companies I don't know of any
other business in America that puts
shell companies when you what do you
produce you don't produce any products
and if you're an expert when it comes to
foreign policy why isn't Italy or the UK
or France hiring you why is it just
Ukraine Russia China Romania and why is
the then at the time advocating and
putting your family members on boards
that you want action in why are you
providing these families Porsches why
are you saying you have no no saying in
this business but now we find lo and
behold you've gone to dinners and after
those dinners 3.5 million dollars flows
why do you say you have no money from
China came but now we proved it I think
there's enough proof out there that this
Biden family needs to come forward and
show there wasn't a pay to play a
America deserves more and Americans want
to know and the one thing I will tell
you is as this Congress the people's
Congress we will follow the facts and
provide it to the American public just
like the Constitution tells us to do
speaker McCarthy thank you we'll follow
it closely hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else